ايرادات طبعا دائما الحكومه في تقديرها
الايرادات تكون متحفضه لانه ناخذ في
الاعتبار المخاطر في الاقتصاد العالمي
اللي ممكن تطرا في اي وقت ولذلك كانت
التحفظات السابقه ايضا همم او التقديرات
سابقه كانت متحفظه الزياده الاساسيه جاءت
من الجزئين الايرادات غير النفطيه
تحققت همم بالنسبه اعلى من مكان متوقع لان
النشاط الاقتصادي كان اعلى الان اصبحت
ايرادات النفطيه مرتبطه بالنشاط
الاقتصاديه هي نسبه تقريبا
16.8% من الناتج المحلي غير النفطي
16.8 فكل ما زاد ال- همم النشاط الاقتصادي
كلما زادت الارادات
هذا جزء وبالتالي لانه النشاط ااا
الاقتصادي للقطع الخاص لسنه 22 تقريبا
سنصل الى 5.9 هذا ادى الى زياده الايرادات
غير النفطيه جزء طبعا من الايرادات
النفطيه لانه كان ايضا نتحفظ في تقديراتها
الان وصلتنا ارقام المحدثه من وزاره
الطاقه وبالتالي صار في فرق 12 مليار
اضافيه في الفوائد
اذا نظرنا الى الارادات 2022 المحقق
تريليون و234 العام القادم تريليون 130
مليار فهي ليست اقل بكثير علما انه 22 كان
فيها سعر نفط قياس المتوسط كان عالي وصلنا
ببران 328 باعلى سعر والانتاج الانتاج
السعوديه كان قبل الاعلان عن التخفيضات
الاخيره تخفيضات الانتاج دخلت حيث التنفيذ
نوفمبر فبالتالي ستؤثر على العام القادم
لم تؤثر على 2022 من هنا السؤال هل انتم
متحفظين ام لا بس نفط المجدول لل 2003 23
الارادات عاليه بالفعل المجرد اولا النهج
اللي اتبعته المملكه خلال الاربعه يعني
مهم جدا نستحضر الخلفيه اخر خمس سنوات صار
في اعاده هيكله كبيره جدا
للمريه العامه ومن ضمن هذا زياده
همم المشاركه الايرادات غير النفطيه في
المجمل الاراده كانت اقل من تقريبا 9% في
2015 اهلا وصلنا الى 16.8 تقريبا 17% هذا
بالتالي يخفف من اثر تقلبات اسعار الطاقه
تقريبا 60% من الايرادات لكنها اقل من
السابق كانت بشكل 90% هذا السبب السبب
الثاني نشوف في بيان الميزانيه اللي نشر
قليل وضعنا ثلاثه سيناريوس
للايرادات سيناريو الاساسي اللي معلن
للسنه القادمه وفي سيناريو متحفظ اكثر
اخدا في الاعتبار التطورات الاقتصاد
العالمي والضغوط سواء من ناحيه
فائده وخلافه وفي سيناري اخر همم اكثر
تفاعلا ياخذ في الاعتبار ما قد ينتج من
ركود اقل من المتوقع وحتى انفتاح بهذا
الاسواق اما في ذلك اسواق الصين واقتصاد
الصين ابكر من المتوقع كده الحالتين
الماليه العامه تاخدها في الاعتبار عندنا
سريعات للتعامل مع الارادات الاقل وسنرها
التعامل مع الارادات بس نحن عم نحكي عن
البيسكيز سناريو بس قبل ان اختم هذه
الجزئيه بال22 كم كان متوسط
الاسعار 101 تقريبا
بنهايه ربع الثالث 149 مليار ونصف انا هنا
العام على قائد 102 مليار بالتالي في
انفاق ارتفع بالربع الرابع ما هو
ليس بالضروره شيء لانه
انفاق ترتفع
الانفاق ارتفع ولا حتى يمكن الارادات
مستوى الارادات انخفاض لانوس اسعار النفط
انخفضت لكن بشكل عام الانفاق السنوي على
مدى الاربع خمس سنوات اللي راحت بدا
يتوازن اول كنا نشوف انفاق قليل جدا في
الاربع في الثلاثه ارباع الاولى ومن ثم
نشوف زياده كبيره جدا في الربع الاخير بدا
هذا يتقلص لانه صار في اداره اكثر
للتدفقات النقديه اداره تحسنت عند الجهات
الحكوميه برفع المطالبات
العمليه هذه مثلا اعتماد القطاع الخاص بدا
يستطيع الان رفع المطالبات في وزاره
الماليه وبالتالي التابع مع الجهاز الدفع
صار الدفع احسن بس بشكل عام ربع الرابع
دائما يكون في انفاق اكثر لان في تسويات
فيه همم معالجات محاسبيه حتى ما بعض
الجهات الاخرى اللي يرتفع فيها الان فقط
معالي الو في اخر لقاء لنا سالتك عن توزيع
الفوائد ذكرت لاربع ابواب همم لدعم
الاحتياطي العام للدوله البيئه ايفون دي
اف المشاريع الاساسيه واطفاء دين فيك
تعطينا توزيع هذا الفائض كيف سيتم بان هذه
الابواب وهل غلطت باي من الابواب ام لا هي
اربعه يعني اعتقد هي اربعه
يعني نستمر فيها هي التوزيع ياتي بعد
انتهاء بعد اقفال السنه الماليه النظاما
بموجب النظام المحاسبي للقطاع العام ما
الان ما نقدر نقول مثلا يتحقق الفاعل
فعليا لما تقفل الحسابات في نهايه السنه
الجزء الاغلب بروح لزياده الاحتياط لكن لم
يتكرر ذلك القرار في النهايه اللجنه
الماليه تقرر كم سيذهب الى الاحتياطات كم
سيذهب الى صندوق التنميه كم سيذهب الى
السوق استمارات العامه كم سيذهب الى سداد
لانه حاليا لا نعتقد انه بيذهب همم شيء من
الاحتياطات اللي سداد الدين فقلصت لك
اياها من اربع الى ثلاثه خلينا بس اسالك
فولو كويشن ما تم الاتفاق يعني كمان صندوق
الاستثمارات العامه بده يوضع ميزانيه
وبالتالي ما في ارادي اتفاق على كم سيذهب
الى تدعيم صندوق الاستثمارات العامه صندوق
الاستثمارات العامه لا يوجد لدي اطلاقا
تحدي في السيوله فاذا كانت يذهب له شيء من
من الفوائد سيكون زياده راس مال لا
يحتاجها لسنه 23 عشان بس نكون واضحين سنه
في العام العامه عنده مجلس اداره المستقل
همم
يقرها عندما يكفي من السيوله والاصول
للتعامل مع حاجاتهم للانفاق في سنه 23
نحنا نتكلم على مبدا ممم هل نحتاج الى
وجود هذه
الفوائد في الاحتياطي ام نصل الى مرحله ان
اعتقد من الافضل ان يتم استغلالها
وتوجيهها
لصندوق استماره العامه او صندوق التنميه
الوطنيه لاستغلالها اكثر في تنميه
الاقتصاد المحليه فاذن الان تذهب الى
الاحتياطي ومن بعده بيصير في قرار من
الاحتياطي
معالي الوزير الاحتياطي النقد الاجنبي لدى
اسامه ملفت انه من سنه لم يرتفع لماذا
تقريبا
الفرق بشكل عام انه عندنا يعني نفقات راس
ماليه هائله ليس فقط في الحكومه في
الحكومه في القطاع الخاص في صندوق
الاستثمارات العامه اللي في البداياتها قد
تتطلب واردات اكثر احنا مازلنا في مرحله
التوطين استبدال الوالدات في المنتجات
المحليه هذا الاستراتيجيه تاخذ وقت الى ان
تكتمل في بدايتها سيكون هناك فعلا واردات
اكبر وبالتالي تستهلك جزء من الاحتياطي
الاجنبي لكن اعتقد انه كان في زياده خلال
السنه بالنسبه للمشاريع الاساسيه
والاستراتيجيه هذا الباب الثالث خلينا
نقول لاستخدام الاحتياطي ماذا تقصدون بها
واي يعني اعطينا فكره اوضح عن هذا الباب
اعطيكي امثله همم في خلال الجائحه في 20
سنه 20 20 21 همم بعد استراتيجيات تم
تاجيل تنفيذ هذا لانه ما كان بالامكان
تنفيذ السياحه على سبيل المثال بالامكان
التنفيذ جزء من استراتيجياتهم عندك كلام
فرصه طالما عندك القدره الماليه
وعندك القدره على التنفيذ
وعندك الانتاجيه همم الاقتصاد ما زال فيه
فجوه الاقتصاد قادر على النمو
بمراحل كبيره الى الان تستطيع ان تعجب
تقول اللي فاتكم في سنه 20 21 عطني خطه في
سنه 23 ولا حتى في 22 سويناها جزئيا 23
انك تعجل ببعض
المبادرات حقتك اعلنا عن مبادره مثلا
استراتيجيه الصناعه الوطنيه
24 و25
اذا كان عندنا القدره على التموين نقول
لهم مش المبادرات الاكثر اثرا لتمكين
القطاع الخاص
والتنميه الاقتصاد اللي ممكن ناجر فيها
وهكذا على مجموعه اخرى
همم
بدي استوضح منك نحن دائما نقول الجيجا
بروجيكس والمشاريع ضخمه مموله من صندوق
الاستثمارات العامه ولكن اليس هناك جزئيه
من الحكومه من الميزانيه مثل البنا تحتيه
لها وغيره مثلا
فيه امم عندنا مخصص في الميزانيه اوكي
للمشاريع الكبرى سنويا
لماذا يخصص لانه فيه
المشاريع ليست بالضرور فقط الصندوق مشاريع
حتى القطاع الخاص الاخرى المشاريع النوعيه
تحتاج الى بنيه تحتيه تحميلها للقطاع
الخاص او للصندوق ليس من الهاتف لانه
يفترض ان الحكومه متوفر
البنيه التحتيه الاساسيه لتوصيل
الخدمات الى هذه المشاريع هذه لنا لها
ميزانيه من ضمن ميزانيه الحكومه سنويا
الميزانيه اللي مخصصه اعتقد العام الماضي
كانت في حدود 30 او اكثر من 30 مليار
صحيح
كمان اعتقد رقم مشابه تقريبا ونفس الشيء
يمكن فيه 24 فيها يعني مشاريع بنيه تحتيه
للمشاريع الكبرى ستستمر لانه تنفيذ حتى
المشاريع الكبرى هو على مدى سنوات الى 20
30 همم معالي الوزير لانه الوقت ضيق اسالك
بعض الاسئله السريعه بالنسبه لموضوع
الضرائب اليوم السعوديه بدها تكون منافسه
للجذب القطاع الخاص ولكن موضوع الفرق
الضريبي مثلا
مثلا عمولات الوافد ترجع التؤثر سلبا على
التنفسيه المملكه وبالتالي هل في اي نيه
لتغيير هذين الامرين الفات وعموله
الوافدين اولا في في
اقتصاد زيد اقتصاد المملكه امن المهم جدا
ان تنظر الى مجموعه من العلويات
والاصلاح الهيكل احيانا يتطلب النظره
الشامل
المهم هو كم اجمالي العب الاقتصادي على
القطاع الخاص من الرسوم ولا من النظره
في الدراسات صندوق النقد الدولي حتى
المؤسسات دوليه الاخرى بما في ذلك ال ال
اي سي سي دي او منظمه التجاره والتعاون
الاقتصادي الدولي
الاوبتيما بالنسبه للدوله مثل المملكه
اللي هي منتجه
للمواد خام تقريبا 21% من 19 الى 21%
اللاعب الضريبي العبه الضريبي في المملكه
حاليا تقريبا
16.16.9% فما زال العبد الضريبي الاجمالي
على القطاع الخاص اقل من متوسط
الدول الاخرى
الحكومه تنظر بشكل يعني مستمر له دوري مع
وزاره الاقتصاد وزاره الماليه وجهات اخرى
بما في ذلك مركز في مركز الحكومه الى كيف
يمكن ان نحسن من ذلك كيف يمكن ان نخفف
الاعباء بما في ذلك عبال التزام
والامتثال على القطاع الخاص فيما يتعلق
بهذه الشريحه اللي نعتقد انها كبيره حاليا
متعدده من الرسوم والمقابلات الماليه في
دراسه قائمه لمحاوله وضعها بطريقه تساعد
القطاع الخاص لكن لا تزال في اطار تقريبا
الايراد متوسط الايرادات الحاليه بس الان
لا قرار بتغييرها
اخر سؤال موضوع الدين العام همم ما في
ذكرت همم اي توجه لاطفاء همم دين بالفتره
القادمه لماذا اهلك ان توضح لنا نصره
جيتكم بالنسبه
للمستوى الدين
همم نسبه الدين الى
ناتج المحل الاجمالي في السعوديه
اقل من متوسط مجموعه العشرين مجموعه ال 20
اذا اخرجنا المملكه تقريبا 85% متوسط
الدائره الناتج محل الاجمالي في المملكه
تقريبا
سنه 22 على تقريبا 24 فاصل تسعه اقل من
25% فما زال عندنا مجال السؤال هو ليس
زياده الدين او تخفيضه والسؤال هل من
المصلحه هل في عائد انك تستدير اكثر
وبالتالي تستخدم هذه الاموال
في عناصر منتجه في الاقتصاد تحقق لك عائد
اكبر اذا الاجابه نعم
سنتين اكثر
لكن اخدا في الاعتبار طبعا اوضاع السوق
تكلفه الدين اللي بدات ترتفع من المهم
دارتها بحصافه مركز اداره الدين عمل عمل
مميز صراحه خلال سنوات السابقه جزء من
الديون اللي تستحق سنه 23 وبعضها سنه 25
في سنه 21 سنه 22 22
سنستمر في ذلك اما لزياده الدين لتمويل
المشاريع زياده الدين لاعاده تمويل همم
ديوان ستستحق في المستقبل او حتى التمويل
البديل همم عندنا خيارات كبيره جدا لتمويل
بعض البنيه التحتيه
المياه
المعالجه الصرف الصحي وغيرها من البنيه
التحتيه اللي قد نستخدم التمويل البديل
شكرا جزيلا لك على هذا اللقاء شكرا علي
وزير الماليه شكرا لك